what's going on she just hit my trailer
and I was trying to talk Sheed me out
she she don't need to be driv getbody
here
me she cring me out for no reason so to
be clear the girl the car with the lady
hit the dude with the semi and the
dude's a whole ass [__] not just like a
half [__] or half grown [__] a full
grown whole ass not half
ass a whole ass
[__] all right here we go let's find
out let's find out what she has to say
what the [__] do you want [__]
whoa that is a wild way to talk to a cop
hey this
[__] yo what the [__] do you
want [__] and and you know it's not
it's I look I like the fact that you
rolled that yeah you it's more dramatic
this is more dramatic than this she wait
till whole [__] was down she went what
the [__] do you want [__] that was
crazy license I do have
a get the [__] I need I need your for
what you just been for what
you've been involved in a CRA I ain't
been involved in no CRA you have this
car hit okay this car ain't been hit all
right I need your license [__] go turn
your car off ma'am no we we're not
playing that
ma'am get the [__] out my car [__] open
the
door oh yeah you
got oh
yeah oh yeah you got me up that's why
all the [__] on call on call he put me
on rest for no reason back yep under
back yep he got me under ARR for no
reason
yep I can't even keep a straight face
you got that Pudding Pop face PR no
reason really oh [__] my girl PR no
reason
Y no you ain't touching my [__]
what hey they touching my phone yo
record this [__] right now real
[__] record this [__] right
now okay you hear that voice
cracking record this [__] right now she
is drunk real [__] she is drunk she she
ain't talking like a gangster no
more [__] oh [__] ma'am all right
you're
okay one2 do you have a patrol unit
coming down
here chill don't do that don't try to
take don't try to get off the don't try
to get off the cup in the
[Music]
car volume reduced for view of safety
cuz she started whing she was whing so
much that the compressor in the camera
when yo that's the edit the person
edited it I
know pop that [__] back
in stay in the
car stay in the car
[Music]
okay she's going to jail just come south
from T Fox we're in the northbound lane
stop
stop get the [__] off me stop get the
[__] off
me your vehicle up and come south from
pal box in front of this vehicle so it
can flick her like your
car headquarters I do not need to
standel she's Tain she just
loud okay chill okay get off
me get off me all right let's see where
this goes after stand up stand up stand
up stand up stand up sit
down sorry we could hear you on the
radio you going to hear all right what
you're going to do is you're going to
turn around y we're going to come up
there
we couldn't hear you bro
yeah so yeah you need to turn down the
soundtracks of whatever the hell hey uh
what you got that a soundtrack of
bodyguard H turn that [__] up y right
sir yeah you or anything I just didn't
want her to drive no more so I say ma'am
I'm just trying to tell you it ain't no
big deal but I could tell she didn't
need to drive that's why I called in
officer find he was walking up when I
was on the phone at 911 hey Kudos St for
calling the cops yeah she don't need to
drive it sound like she on something so
you know shout out to the man who
decided to call the police cuz he's like
you know what this fender bender is fine
but you should not be on the road you
going to kill somebody you on that gesus
juice yeah ma'am so my name is Alara
okay I work for the Paco police what you
want to tell me what's going on today
you me what's telling you on what's
going on today are you okay what what's
going
on why is
that
I thought I was going to be
okay but you're not okay no why is that
I thought I was going to be taken home
but I'm not taking home from where from
whatever okay do you know what happened
just now no I don't know what happened
okay I just know I'm in handcuffs that's
s you don't remember anything before
then no like what the [__] am I supposed
to understand before then like I'm in
handcuffs like
I don't know what else to say okay can
you sit up for me no Hey where's all
that tough attitude you had earlier was
talk about get the [__] out my face
[__] now look at you crying moing on
the floor stand up no [__] Hey listen
some of y'all don't know the uh thing I
like to call consequences she real she
come visit sometimes too knock knock she
like Santa Claus but she only show up
when you [__] up and her gift
retribution [__] you better not cry you
you better not bout you better not shout
I'm telling you why consequences coming
tonight and tomorrow if you [__] up and
a day after that if you [__] up too and
whenever you're going to [__] up it's
going to be retributions that's what
happened you got here talking to a cop
hey then [__] you there [__] and you
know
just consequences don't hey Take These
Cuffs off me [__] what the [__] you
think this is I ain't giving you nothing
[__] you going to jail now I don't feel
SI
okay
consequence this video is brought to you
by surf shark stop what you're doing
right now just quick reminder you need
serf shark in your life why well serf
shark is a VPN changer if you're using
public Wi-Fi the public Wi-Fi is
actually filthy because all the
information is not encrypted if you have
the surf shark it encrypts the
information for you so that if you doing
transaction it's safer uhhuh not only
that it comes with an antivirus do you
know that surf shark is the only VPN
changer that your there's no limits in
the devices yeah if you have three
phones one subscription boom three
phones why would you have three phones I
don't know that's your business though
and if you click on the link below right
now click on the link use code promo
code ABA and preach you're going to be
able to have on top of your subscription
3 months for free uh-huh and there's a
30-day money back warranty get yourself
uh a VPN changer to be a little bit more
safe cuz you're on the public Wi-Fi
right now and that [__] is
filthy the things that people do on the
public Wi-Fi sit up okay sit up for me
just for a second then I'll let you lay
back down okay here face your feet that
way for me okay in this story there's no
back cups just good cops oh
yeah there's no backup it's just like
frankly guys I really don't know what
the [__] is going on and what's
happening she just did this and the
camera footage just shows exactly that
it's good cops good cops for once it's
just like Hey listen here honey yes okay
listen here I'm I just I just need you
to get back up and then I'll lay you
back down okay [__] you see how easily
and like how he just handle that you
know he's Deck with this a few times
before you don't need to there's a lot
of be wild people out here who just need
to be going to jail y'all think I'm
slick y'all think I'm [__] slick y
put these [__] on somebody else y'all
think y put these
[__] y' put these [__]
up oh my God shut the [__] up
that it's like I've seen some parents do
that when I'm at the mall yeah kid is
crying and you know you got to put them
in the seat in the back and they
M
boom she shut the door that's how it
felt like put that [__] off I ain't
taking I'm not taking okay I'm not if
that's what we're doing with insulting
people I'm not taking nothing off all
right boom close the door you could you
could you you you can yell in that
soundproof
car I got I got not
you I forgot I
got like she she Northbound she hit the
car I was called to disturbance when I
got there U she was in the driver's seat
single occupant I asked her to step on
the car she start dog C me up and
down I was trying to essentially stop
her from exiting the premises and she's
decided to proceed anyways we trying to
close the window at which point I
reached inside unlocked the apartment
took out the keys and put her in
handcuffs and now she
like I can see a black lives matter
rally just passing by the cops car be
like black lives matter they open the
car they be like not that black Liv
let's carry
on being selective as [__] yeah yeah we
leaving some of you in cop cars police
brutality no police need to brutalize
you shut the [__] up she tried to roll
up the window I had to push it down
unlock the car from side turn the car
off and then detain her and she's she
tried to get out car tell car cuz it was
tried to kick me um she just refused
every command for me I swear
to you want to press charges oh I'm okay
no we she just has to me she resisted
everything uh she doesn't
[Music]
need well shout out to the cop he cuz he
could have he could have gone the could
could could assault arrest oh yeah you
could have [__] [__] her up he like no
I'm good she's just crazy so shout out
to this cop shout outs to you shout out
to this cop you didn't have to do that
cuz I honestly if you would have press I
would i' be like well she she did she
she to hit the gas she did do it yeah
she did do it and then onong cam yeah so
so I mean I even mad at him so I'm just
saying good for him I'm
sorry Mom
sorry are you think this sounded like
the world's tiniest violet yeah yo yo I
don't know who the editor is who got who
like requisitioned all these the the
editor but he's like the viewers need to
see this get give me all the juice yo
give me that 4 seconds of her cry from M
inside inside inside inside give me
inside of the car do you have the audio
of inside the car you do can I get that
please a thank you you're nice he
watched that whole recording to get that
4sec snippet he laughed too yeah shout
outs to this guy body can't
watch can you sit up for me no I cannot
sit up for you what time out wait you're
telling the cup that cuffed you time out
you're in timeout literally from
society you're getting Society timed out
no I'm not going to stop because guess
what you don't give a stop pulling stop
step
out step out we can do this the easy you
want to grab a roller arm the quicker we
can get you inside the they can get you
help come
on
she goes from crying please please [__]
you [__] like the mood swings this girl
needs medication she needs Ms she really
unstable I want to blame it on the
alcohol but it's more it's a little bit
more than that she
got got me [__] up you got you got you
[__] up yep the only person that got
you [__] up is you boo boo you woke up
today and you said I me how can I [__]
up my life you said can I get toast with
a cup of [__] up yep and you brw it
yourself yep and then you drank it got
in your car de started to piss all over
the street and you got some hiccups from
the fuckups but the fuckups is really
you her name is Kimberly Solomon middle
name [__] up Kimberly [__] up
Solomon that's you there's a ring to it
I'm not going to lie through it good for
her
my
[Applause]
H yeah that's a down this is like
they're going to enter the door there's
going to be a go that's crazy
[Applause]
though
God help
me no
[Applause]
here
no we don't have the arrest the
deal yo what
they got the psychiatric chair for no
it's a restraining chair yeah it's not
psychiatric it's just a restraining that
they have in those uh precincts and
stuff like that they definitely have
that that means that you're you can't do
[__] you can't the angle that is you
can't even get up you can't no and
you're strap y hold hold on hold on
you're at the door I heard you you were
in the car I heard you yeah yeah all
right uh get the chair of course all
right well that's it for today's video I
need just just skim through that cuz
that was a lot of no no no no there's a
lot of screaming and there uh yeah go
drink and drive take your meds mental
health [__] around and find
out all them things it's prle yeah all
them things that wi soup it's not to
laugh at mental health and stuff like
that it's real it's real but when you
don't when you don't when you don't take
care of it [__] like that will happen it
can't happen and I've seen that [__]
happen so yeah be wary of that people be
be really hey it's your responsibility
to medicate you don't that's on you it
is you're a grown ass person you got a
DUI I'm not going to feel sorry for you
sorry not going to do it want to know
why cuz you could have been on the
streets killing somebody else so they
catch your ass and they put you in
jaila he go to jail don't collect 200
there you
go and stop playing